there's no shortage of graffiti in most
downtowns from simple tags to intricate
murals it can be found in almost any
alley underpass and subway tunnel to
most people who live and work there it
all blends into the background but one
piece of street art isn't so easy to
ignore since unlike most graffiti this
one is animated john freeman an
unassuming man in his mid-20s was out
late one night in april 2004. it was a
saturday so he'd let loose a little more
than he originally intended and he was
starting to feel the effects so he went
out back for some fresh air this wasn't
the most popular bar in the city so when
he opened up the door and stepped out he
found himself completely alone despite
that fact he couldn't shake the sense
that he was being watched he looked
around squinting and trying his best to
focus his eyes just then john thought he
spotted someone behind the dumpster so
he decided to investigate when he looked
behind the dumpster there was no one to
be found instead painted on the wall was
a piece of street art it was a strange
piece of art too a half-human half-owl
creature rendered in highly realistic
detail the figure was crouched over and
its eyes faced outwards eyes that looked
far too real like they were staring at
him right out of the wall following him
as he swayed from side to side there was
something so wrong about it its intense
gaze its sharp beak its grasping claws
how could anyone paint something like
this it looked like it could crawl right
out of the bricks something about the
painting made him nervous but he
couldn't look away he was drawing him in
beckoning him there was something about
it that jon just couldn't resist he
stepped closer until he was close enough
to reach out and touch him what john
didn't know was that he was also close
enough for it to reach out and touch him
before he could react he saw the
painting come to life the feathers
ruffle the hands prepare to grab the
beak opens up for john it was already
too late from inside the bar the other
patrons heard a loud scream from the
alley the bartender ran outside to see
what was going on but when he got there
all he found was a blood stain on the
concrete there was no sign of john
freeman and there was no graffiti on the
wall this is just one of the dozens of
recorded attacks attributed to what the
scp foundation has designated
scp-1155 or the predatory street art it
can appear on any wall in any major
metropolitan area but it prefers ones
that are out of the way and isolated
such as back alleys lonely parking
structures subway tunnels and
underpasses the creature depicted in the
street art has the long sinewy arms of a
human with the head and feathery body of
a large owl and though its pose changes
often it's always facing out watching
the foundation is no stranger to deadly
works of art such as the infamous
scp-173
the living sculpture who will snap your
neck if you stop looking at it or
scp-1074 the abstract art capable of
psychologically enthralling the viewer
and leading them into a state of
catatonia if exposed for too long
however what sets
scp-1155 apart from these other two is
the fact that it's incredibly hard to
contain and its methods are particularly
violent and gruesome but more on that
later if you spot this odd painting
while you're out walking with friends
you probably wouldn't give it a second
thought but if you're alone it's a
different story this scp has an almost
hypnotic effect when viewed by a lone
person if you spot it you'd be
overwhelmed by curiosity and you'll feel
compelled to get a closer look you can
potentially resist this hypnotic effect
with some effort especially if you're
aware of its anomalous properties
meaning knowledge really is power when
it comes to scp-1155
once you get within two meters of
scp-1155 though the creature will jump
out of the wall and strike with attacks
usually following the same pattern first
the victim will be restrained to prevent
struggle or escape the eyes and tongue
will then be removed followed by the
amputation of the hands and feet the
victim will then be disemboweled and the
intestines and stomach removed all in as
little as six seconds but not all of
these attacks result in death some have
actually managed to survive attacks by
the predatory street art with those
lucky few being eligible for class a
amnesty therapy courtesy of the
foundation in most cases though there's
no survivors to find and often not even
a body at all once
scp-1155 has begun its attack and if it
remains unspotted it will snatch up its
prey and vanish before appearing on the
wall somewhere else the foundation has
made attempts to discover where the
bodies end up by equipping d-class test
subjects with gps trackers but the
results of these tests have been
inclusive recorded relocation events
have covered distances as small as 15
meters or as far as 800 kilometers but
the true range of this creature's
movement is unknown if caught in the act
of feeding though
scp-1155 will disappear leaving its
victim behind usually in these cases the
victim will bleed out and die but some
have survived two such survivors were
d-class personnel who were used for
tests to see what happened when the
attacks were interrupted both were
incoherent and badly wounded following
the attacks their eyes were gone and one
of them also had his tongue hands and
feet removed though neither could
adequately communicate what had happened
to them the one who still had a tongue
claimed to still be able to see in spite
of his missing eyes and that he was
still looking through his stolen eyes he
described what he could see a kind of
grizzly pantry where it appeared
scp-1155 had stashed the remains of its
previous victims perhaps to feed on
later this d-class managed to escape
from on-site quarters during an
unrelated containment breach running
back to where he had been attacked by
scp-1155
he was pursued by law enforcement who
had been told by the scp foundation that
he was an escaped mental patient
suffering from serious delusions the
police chased him for several blocks
before he disappeared down an alleyway
officers at the scene reported hearing a
scream but when they got to where it
came from there was no sign of the
d-class just a dead-end alley with a
blank wall the other d-class the one
with no tongue was successfully
relocated to an undisclosed location
while the patient was being moved though
foundation surveillance noted an
increased level of movement from
scp-1155
the painting was appearing and
disappearing and in each relocation its
posture suggested hunting and tracking
behavior as if it was pursuing the one
who got away the places it was
manifesting also became more and more
public at one point it appeared on the
side of a building right in the middle
of town though it was too high up to be
reached by any of the hundreds of
witnesses while all of this was
happening the d-class being held for
medical treatment was becoming
increasingly distressed the foundation
theorized that the entity may have been
frustrated at losing its prey and that
it would likely continue to relocate in
and out of highly visible areas until
the d-class was returned to it because
of this the executive decision was made
to take the d-class to the outskirts of
the city
scp-1155 manifested in the area and the
team left both it and the d-class
unobserved
both the creature and the d-class soon
disappeared and
scp-1155 resumed its more manageable
hunting behavior due to this scp's
ability to jump from place to place it
has proven difficult if not impossible
to contain and as a well-earned ketter
class designation as a result at first
the foundation tried physically removing
the wall on which the scp had manifested
but this only caused it to relocate a
similar result happened following
attempts to paint over or damage the
painting current containment procedures
involve closely monitoring the disused
shopping mall lot where
scp-1155 currently seems to live for
lack of a better term the mall has been
marked as condemned and foundation
agents continually monitor the area
posing as security guards to dissuade
any civilian traffic from entering the
danger zone mobile task force pi one
nicknamed the city slickers tried to
obscure any surface on which the
creature appeared but this didn't end
well first the team leader ordered that
a vending machine be placed in front of
the graffiti while it was located in an
alley that transients were known to
frequent this was supposed to be only a
temporary stop gap intended to stop any
unsuspecting person from falling under
scp-1155's hypnotic spell in time a
proper containment zone would be
established with more agents forming a
security perimeter around the area but
by the time the extra resources arrived
and the vending machine was moved the
painting had disappeared it had
responded to the obstruction by
relocating and reappearing on a wall at
a nearby children's playground the
foundation quickly mobilized
interrupting
scp-1155 in the middle of an attack in
order to trigger another relocation but
sadly several lives were already lost by
the time they arrived the entire ordeal
was a tragic and costly mistake on the
foundation's part it seems that when
scp-1155 is obstructed it gets angry
instances where it relocated after being
obstructed more often than not resulted
in it moving to a much more public place
that would be harder to contain for the
foundation while it previously appeared
in low traffic areas it now seemed
emboldened following containment
attempts and was readily appearing in
public spaces it was argued that all of
humanity would be better off allowing a
few people to be taken by scp-1155
every couple of years then risk it
ending up in a heavily populated area
where it could endanger who knows how
many people before it was noticed the
foundation continued to research
possible containment procedures though
and eventually figured out the perfect
minimum distance at which they could
create a barrier so that it wouldn't be
noticed by the scp itself this was one
of their more expensive containment
protocols
as it required purchasing an entire mall
only to shut it down and condemn it
under the pretense of there being a
dangerous sinkhole underneath it the
expense seems to have been worth it
though as
scp-1155 is currently still inside the
parking structure connected to the mall
the mall and the parking structure are
under round-the-clock surveillance via
motion capture security cameras and
while there have been no other
relocations there's no telling what
might trigger one again so if you live
in a big city and you find yourself
walking alone at night keep an eye on
the street art if you spot a painting of
half human half owl that you could swear
wasn't there before resist the urge to
check it out and just cross the street
instead now go check out another tale of
a man-eating monster
scp-082 ferdinand the cannibal or
scp-3001 red reality for one of the
scariest anomalous locations known to
man